how does communication change as you
grow from 10 to 20 to 30 employees yeah
so it you know you want to take that
rubric you've already created of
communication and you just build on it
so instead of looking at you know your
twelve-week plan you're looking at a
12-month plan and you're tracking the
employees across that you know you want
to make sure they know what the top
revenue goal is what you know whatever
their if they're its person on the sales
team what their their goal for the for
the year is if it's someone who's
launching syndicates what you know how
many syndicates they need to launch in
that year it's really important that you
are that you communicate with the on the
individual level as you start to grow so
it's it's you've likely now split out
into teams so each team has their goals
over 12 months instead of the instead of
like the you know the company as a whole
and it's mmm it's also important that
you to do this you also could have you
have meetings yeah
usually weekly azbest yeah at 10 20 30
employees
hopefully you have space for all of
those for one meeting but it's not
you're past the point where everyone
gets to talk at a meeting yeah so it's
really important at this stage to start
with the anxiety yeah to start with the
problem so who who needs help you now
have a pool of 20 or 30 people that can
actually help with solve these problems
it's not just to five people in an
office just grinding and trying to solve
all the problems across the company and
maybe being under-resourced now you have
some you know some weight to the team
and people can help each other out you
can do you know barn raisings where
you're just researching a certain topic
you all sit heads down for 20 minutes
and then you share your research yeah
and you can still make the 12 month plan
if you have a small team I encourage you
to do that but it might be harder to
track when you're more nascent and have
smaller teams against just you know a 12
month plan it might be way too much and
you're going to get to the point at some
point where you can't have everybody in
the room as you're saying speaking in a
in a in a meeting which you can do when
you have 10 right we go around the table
here at our staff lunch but now that
we're 14 maybe half the people we go
around the table and talk and we try to
rotate who gets to talk each week but
it's a differ
type of communication that's going to
occur and you're going to need to invest
in your communications tools as we see
here and the third point what tools do
you think when you start getting to that
15 to 25 people you're gonna want to
start using what tools yeah actually
Sam Sam can talk about that cuz she's
gonna she is going to talk about tools
for the internal communication